a rough week for the banking industry
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank is
causing shock waves across the entire
business world
a big Bank just died we've all heard
about it everyone's talking about it and
we gotta talk about it because something
big is going on here as of this morning
Silicon Valley Bank or svb has gone
under completely the second biggest bank
collapse in U.S history the bank is
called the Silicon Valley Bank or if
we're going to call it svb in this video
it is the epicenter of tech startups
venture capital and it is now
effectively dead the government is
scrambling to keep us all calm while
this Bank fails your deposits will be
there when you need them the American
banking system is really safe and well
capitalized that's because we live in a
system that doesn't work if everyone
freaks out at the same time
the system relies on all of us keeping a
feeling of safety if that doesn't happen
the system falls apart and that's what
I'm going to explain today so let me
show you how this happened how this Bank
failed and what it means for you and me
but more importantly how this moment
teaches us that our bank accounts are
kind of a lie we're gonna have to do
something different here we're actually
rescuing depositors in banks that made
some bad decisions over the course of
the last year or so Americans can have
confidence
the banking system is safe okay so let's
talk about Banks all this is done with
credit credit created by the bank out of
the deposits made by all of us banks are
actually pretty nuts we think of a bank
as like a place where we take our money
and store it like we give our money to
the bank people and they go put it in a
giant Vault and it is safe until we need
it but that is not what is happening in
reality banks are doing something pretty
magical when you give them your money
what they do is actually at the heart of
our modern society our modern economy
it's what makes a lot of things work let
me explain let's get a little bit more
insight on the collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank okay for this let's get back
to the old collage of the macro economy
as we've done in previous videos let's
say I put ten thousand dollars into my
bank what's insane is that the bank only
has to keep 10 of that money in the
actual bank 10 percent
so that's like a thousand dollars of my
ten thousand dollars the other nine
thousand dollars they can go out and
invest with and make money on using my
money they can go invest it this often
means giving out loans to people and
collecting interests okay so nine
thousand of my dollars gets loaned out
to let's say a baguette business who is
in need of a business loan because they
need a new oven my bank gives the baker
my money and charges interest on that
loan and they actually give me a little
bit of that interest that they've made
to say like hey thanks for letting me
use your nine thousand dollars so the
baguette business now has nine thousand
of my dollars and I don't actually know
this because I kind of think that my
money is in a vault somewhere so now the
baker with his new loan goes and buys
his oven for nine thousand dollars and
the oven seller takes that nine thousand
dollars and goes and puts it in their
bank and guess what
their Bank does the exact same thing
that my bank did with my money
but now they're doing it with their
money which is kind of my money they
only have to keep ten percent in their
vaults so they only have to put nine
hundred dollars in the vault
they've got 8 100 that they can lend out
and look there's a family who's looking
to spend money on a home and they need a
loan okay wait are you seeing what's
Happening Here I gave 10 grand to my
bank and now that money has magically
duplicated a few times to make more
money like real money that can be used
to buy things an oven and then a house
this continues to happen over and over
and over my 10 grand just keeps getting
used to be lent out put into another
bank and then lent out again in fact if
you model this out on a nerdy
spreadsheet which is something I like to
do you'll see that if I deposited ten
thousand dollars in the bank ten
thousand dollars is added to the system
but then for each one of these
transactions more and more money gets
added to the system this is the
aggregate of all of the money being
added to the system my ten thousand
dollars turns into this look what
happens look
just keeps going and going and
eventually
it effectively 10 X's it sort of flat
lines out at a hundred thousand dollars
what
my ten thousand dollars just turned into
a hundred thousand dollars into the
economy because of
weird mental constructs yes that is our
modern Financial system it is amazing
and it's kind of mind-blowing okay
this magical thing is called the money
multiplier effect and it relies on the
reserve ratio that the requirement that
banks have like the amount that they
have to keep in in this case 10 which is
like the real Reserve ratio right now
you can do this calculations like one
over the reserve ratio and it sort of
gives you this multiplier effect of your
money the crazy thing is the lower the
reserve ratio like if your bank only had
to keep five percent of your money in
the more money would be created out in
the economy but the riskier that would
be for you if the reserve ratio was like
50 if they had to keep fifty percent of
your money then like that's safer for
you but now you're not like priming the
pump of like giving all of this money to
the economy to like make transactions
and build businesses and build
capitalism so the reserve ratio is like
10 right now which means that a bank
that has a hundred million dollars from
all of its customers really only has to
have 10 million dollars in its vault at
all times and the other 90 million is
out doing its work in the economy
multiplying itself and making a return
for the bank and giving you a little
interest rate and the bank is secretly
the whole time like please everyone
don't come withdraw your money at the
same time because we don't actually have
it just please thanks okay so this is
slightly scary right like the bank only
has 10 of my money
feels kind of risky I thought Banks were
like the safest place to put your money
it's not like I'm doing some hardcore
like risky Stock Investing maybe I
should take all my money out of my bank
account and put it under my mattress so
that the bank isn't like playing around
with it well no let's actually not do
that please because if we did our
economy would miss out on this amazing
magical multiplier effect that turns my
10 grand into a hundred grand and our
economy would literally be a fraction as
prosperous as it is the reality is we
don't have to worry and I'm going to
explain that to you in a sec but I first
need to thank the sponsor of today's
video thanks to today's sponsor incogni
some of you may have remembered that a
few years ago I made a video about junk
mail and like the original framing of
that video was I was going to go on a
war on junk mail I was going to try to
unsubscribe from everything and see if I
could rid my life of junk mail
unfortunately the video turned into just
an explainer about how my data is bought
and sold and I gave up on the whole
unsubscribe from all of the junk in this
world why because it was impossible many
of us don't know that our data our
personal information is packaged and
sold on an open market in this shadowy
industry of data Brokers and not just
like one or two data Brokers hundreds
this is a very lucrative industry the
bad news is navigating the system to
successfully extricate yourself from it
is really difficult it's incredibly
tedious by design it would literally
take years this is where incognate comes
in and cognate is a service that you
give permission to go out and remove you
from all of these lists to get you out
of this system it's not an easy process
trust me I tried it but incognia is set
up to do this they reach out to data
Brokers on your behalf and request that
your information be removed and then
they deal with the aftermath if they run
into any issues with their yearly
subscription incogni consistently is
monitoring for you protecting your data
and making sure that you don't end up
back in this system it's actually been
pretty fascinating for me to look at the
dashboard in incognitive and looking and
realizing that I'm on over a hundred of
these lists which explains why my email
inbox is like a disaster and why my
phone is ringing all day from like
random Robo calls but it's also personal
safety like you don't want someone
knowing where you live and what you're
up to it's just like get me out of this
system so I created an account and then
gave incognate permission just like with
a click and now here they're off to the
thing they've sent out 148 requests to
data Brokers I've already been removed
off of 33 of these lists I can't tell
you how satisfying this is I finally
have a tool to fight back against this
shadowy industry so the first hundred
people to click the link in my
description get 60 off using this
service it is incognito.com Johnny
Harris make sure to use the code Johnny
Harris help support this channel also
get you in on the deal thank you and
Cockney for sponsoring this video and
for existing I'm very appreciative let's
get back to the video okay so Banks only
hold on to 10 of my money in the other
90 they are investing in the world and
this is kind of scary governments know
that this is kind of scary and they also
know that our society and our our
economy is built on us keeping our money
in the bank not freaking out not
everyone all of a sudden going and
pulling it out so to make us all sleep
better at night they promise that if a
bank ever does anything Reckless with
our money or they accidentally lose it
while they're out there investing that
the government will make up the
difference that the government will pay
us back for any money that we lost at
least up to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars it's kind of like a
everyone stay calm will pay back if you
lose it just don't everyone go at the
same time and pull out your money please
the whole system relies on it can we
just chill and we can chill as long as
we don't have more than 250 000 in our
bank account anyway this is kind of
works for most people most people don't
have 250 000 lying around
but what about businesses businesses
have to use Banks they have expenses
every month like payroll and rent a tech
company like Roku had 500 million
dollars in Silicon Valley Bank and at
this time the company does not know to
what extent they'll be able to recover
that cash companies like this need way
more than 250 000 to cover their costs
so the question is how do they feel safe
and this is where we get back to Silicon
Valley Bank these Dynamics become very
strange when you're talking about the
customers being a bunch of businesses do
you have the money Jitters ask your
nearest Bank of America branch for a jar
of soothing instant money okay so
Silicon Valley Bank is the bank for
businesses particularly Tech startups in
California and unsurprisingly ninety
percent of their customers had more than
the 250 000 sort of Mark where the
government will insure you so a lot of
that money is not insured by anyone they
just trust their bank and that's fine
Banks aren't out there taking their
customers money and like making super
risky Bets with it this bank has been
operating for 40 years and it's been
doing just fine but what happens next is
a perfect storm of events that led this
bank to sink where is he peekaboo let's
make a list for this here we go the
anatomy of a collapse of a big bang
first they invested a lot of their
customers money like every Bank does in
this case they invested in government
bonds which is a totally safe investment
it's an investment to put your money in
for a certain amount of time like 10
years and the government will pay you
interest on that money based on the
federal interest rate the interest rate
you know the thing that the FED puts up
and down to sort of help put brakes on
the economy the thing is though when svb
bought these bonds it was like last year
and the year before back when rates were
very very low okay not a great return
for them but it was fine it was a safe
investment if they just waited out the
time period of the bond they would get
all their money back plus a little
return okay but then what happens next
economist expect a rate hike of three
quarters of a percent to help drive down
inflation the government starts to raise
interest rates they're doing this to
help Stave off inflation stabilize the
economy the government is doing this
thing called raising interest rates
that's fine what it means is that people
buying bonds today are going to get a
better rate of return those bonds are
more valuable now today so svb who
bought their bonds a couple years ago
when interest rates were super low and
if they ever wanted to sell those bonds
early they're now competing with
interest rates that are a lot higher and
so their bonds are actually worth much
less if they had to sell them today they
would lose money okay but again that's
fine just hold on to your bonds until
the the whole maturity schedule happens
and then the government will give you
all your money back with your little
return everything is okay okay but
here's the next part of the perfect
storm that really starts to heat all
this up remember that svb's customers
are startups startups raise money from
Venture funds and they take that money
and they deposit it into svb and that is
how svb gets its money to operate to
invest with but during this recent
economic downturn startups haven't been
able to raise as much money and thus svb
hasn't had as much money coming in the
door and so they start pulling on their
reserves and they realize they kind of
have to figure out a way to get more
money and it's not going to come from
startups because startups aren't raising
so they turn to their bonds they're like
we've got tons of our customers money in
these really safe bonds they're at low
interest rates we probably need to sell
some of them off to like get some cash
in our reserves to like meet all of our
needs and the withdrawals and all of
that so they sell off a bunch of their
bonds and this is where things start to
go really really wrong they announced
that they're selling their bonds and
they have to sell them early and yes we
bought them at a lower interest rate and
now the interest rate is higher so we're
actually selling them at a loss and that
loss is actually two billion dollars
okay like again banks have to deal with
this kind of stuff this isn't great for
them but it's far from lethal but then
this is where it starts to get really
bad they go out and announce that
they're going to be raising money from
other investors they're like going out
looking for money they're like hey yeah
we sold off the bonds we also need you
guys to invest in our bank so that we
can just stay good everyone stay calm
it's not a big deal we just need to
raise a little money
everyone stay calm but the best way to
like get people to freak out is to be
like stay calm it's actually not the big
of a deal we're fine we just need to
raise some money and we're selling bonds
at a loss oh my God okay it's happening
every everybody
what's the procedure okay so now the
moment that deals the final blow to all
of this all of these Founders and
Venture firms they're all talking to
each other because they're all in the
same community in the same area all in
the same business they're all in the
same WhatsApp groups and they're all
like hey guys uh what's going on with
svb all of our bank why are they raising
money why are they selling their bonds
early is my money not safe and so like a
herd of bison frightened by a loud bang
a stampede of very wealthy Founders and
startups in central California start
pulling out their money from svb trying
to stay safe what you're seeing behind
me is customers of Silicon Valley Bank
lined up to make sure that they can get
their money they know that their
accounts aren't insured by the
government because they have way too
much money
and so they don't feel like their money
is safe and they take it all out I need
money how am I going to live until the
bank opens to play I need cash
how much do you need on Wednesday alone
customers pulled out 42 billion dollars
which was a quarter of what the bank was
worth word spreads to Wall Street that
this is happening and svb's stock begins
to tank the bank stock lost 80 percent
of its value this week 60 in one day
alone yesterday which makes it even
harder for them to go out and raise new
money to meet all of the demands of
people withdrawing drawing drawing their
money there is a panic or as we call it
a run on the bank and so just like that
svb ran out of cash because all of their
customers tried to get their money out
at the same time and were reminded that
the modern banking system is built off
of banks only having a fraction of your
money while the rest of it is out in the
economy turning into more money
we don't want to be reminded of this
very often but when we are it's kind of
scary so the government swoops in to
take over the ship oh but not before the
bank Executives could pay themselves a
bunch of bonuses because they're banking
people and this is what banking people
tend to do so yes by Friday Federal
Regulators stepped in and seized control
of svb's assets it'll go down as the
second largest bank collapse in history
right behind 2008's Washington Mutual
meltdown so since the very beginning of
the modern Financial system the
government has played an important role
in making us feel safe about our bank
accounts even though our bank accounts
are a bunch of mental constructs and
really just a list of ious plus 10 of
your actual money they don't want us to
think that way because if we do chaos
happens and the system collapses you're
you're thinking of this place all wrong
as if I had the money back on a safe the
money's not here well your money's in
Joe's house that's right next to you
doors and in the Kennedy house on Mrs
maclin's house and a hundred others so
when a bank actually does collapse they
have to go into hyper mode this is why
all the like government people were like
working overtime on the weekends and the
first round of intervention the first
thing they need to do is just words
Americans can have confidence that the
banking system is safe today is about
not sinking the boat that we are all in
like this is really important they need
to say that like the government is there
to protect this money like you don't
need to go panic and take all your money
out of the bank you are fine you are
insured because Panic spreads like a
contagion you know this feeling like
when you feel a sense of panic it will
just spread you don't want to be the
last person to act because and we have
some cautionary tales in the 1930s 9 000
banks failed there were huge runs on all
of these Banks there was no 250 000
insurance so people got worried and took
all their money out at the same time and
the whole thing collapsed in the
aftermath of the 2008 financial crisis
500 banks failed and if you remember
there were some banks that were so big
that would have been so catastrophic if
they failed that taxpayers came and
bailed them out gave them all the money
to make good on all of their needs this
is how important it is and in this case
the government pulled out all the stops
to get everyone their money back over
the weekend the Biden Administration
took Extraordinary Measures to guarantee
anyone who had accounts with the
collapse Banks would be able to get back
all of their money regardless of the
amount again 90 of the customers of svb
had accounts of over 250 000 and they
weren't insured and yet the government
was able to give them their money back
technically they didn't use taxpayer
money to do this we don't think we're
not sure but it was actually like a fund
that all the banks paid into so whether
or not this is like another bailout
bailout bailout bailout bailout is hotly
debated and it will continue to be
debated anyway the big debate that I'm
thinking about here is whether or not
the government should let Banks fail or
if they should always swoop in and save
them when you let Banks fail you force
them to feel the consequences of their
decisions on how they manage their Banks
but when you let Banks fail you also
create this feeling of anxiety that is
contagious and right now there already
is a bit of an economic anxiety flooding
around our country inflation is high
there's war there's increased
competition with China and trade
barriers people are slightly on edge and
so the government swooped in with 150
percent of their might to make everyone
feel safe they didn't want to ignite
this into another 2008 style meltdown
this was the safer approach I guess for
me I'm slightly concerned that this may
lead to just more Reckless risk-taking
because we're kind of sending a signal
to these banks that like hey if you fail
even the kind of smaller ones we will
probably bail you out which again is a
good thing this helps quell any chaos
especially in the short term we don't
have people freaking out we have no
reason to go run and pull out all of our
money now and importantly people who
have money in small Regional Banks feel
secure they're not going to take out all
their money and put it in like banks
that are too big to fail but in the long
run it could just mean banks will feel
emboldened to continue with bigger and
bigger bets knowing that the government
will bail them out knowing that there's
not real consequences knowing that
they'll get their bonuses so the debate
is heating up now in a new way you're
going to see a lot of fighting you're
gonna see a lot of Elizabeth Warren
who's very smart on this stuff and also
very bullish about regulating Banks
there will be another financial crisis
of course when the crash comes the big
banks will throw up their hands and say
it's not their fault nobody could have
seen it coming and then they'll run to
Congress and beg for bailout money and
let's be blocked I'll probably get it
and what happens next is we will witness
if this government intervention actually
worked if the government successfully
calmed us all down so that the system
can keep going or if this Panic will
continue to spread leading to more Bank
runs more failed Banks and a stark
reminder that our modern Financial
system is a mental construct that leads
us to all work together for the
prosperity and growth of our society
until that is The Dominoes start to fall
they knew the taxpayers would bail them
out they weren't being stupid they just
didn't care yeah because they're [__]
Crooks
but at least we're going to see some of
them go to jail
right
we didn't have to break up the banks
party's over I don't know
I don't know
I have a feeling that in a few years
people are going to be doing what they
always do when the economy tanks
they will be blaming immigrants and poor
people